♪ ♪
>> IT IS STARTING TO SMELL MORE
AND MORE LIKE COLLUSION TO THE
PUBLIC.
>> IT'S BEGINNING TO LOOK LIKE
CHRISTMAS AND COLLUSION.
>> IF THEY JUST DO THEIR WORK
AND THEIR JOB, THEY WILL FIND
OUT THAT IT WAS COLLUSION.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE IMPEACHED.
I DON'T CARE WHAT OTHERS SAY
ABOUT IT IS TOO SOON, WE DON'T
KNOW, WE THINK.
WHAT MORE DO WE NEED?
>> Tucker: WELL, FOR MORE THAN
A YEAR WE HAVE LISTENED TO
ELECTED DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA
WHO SERVE THEM, HOW ABOUT
RUSSIAN COLLUSION?
WHY WE NEED A FAR-REACHING
ALL-POWERFUL INVESTIGATION TO
UNCOVER ITS COMMAND NOW YOU ARE
UNPATRIOTIC IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE OUR INVESTIGATION, AND
HAS NOT FOUND A WHIFF OF
EVIDENCE THAT ANYBODY COLLUDED
VLADIMIR PUTIN, SO NOW THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN YELLING AT
US FOR A YEAR HAVE DECIDED TO
FORGET THAT THEY EVER SAID
ANYTHING LIKE THIS, NOW CLAIMING
COLLUSION WAS NEVER A POINT AT
ALL.
JUST WANTED TO KNOW WHAT RUSSIA
WAS DOING.
DEVIN NUNES INVOLVED IN THE
INVESTIGATION SINCE THE VERY
BEGINNING, JOINING US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> ALWAYS A PLEASURE, THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE REQUESTED
A NUMBER OF DOCUMENTS FROM
FEDERAL AGENCIES, INTELLIGENCE
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
APPARENTLY HAVE NOT GOT THEM,
WHY IS IT SO DIFFICULT TO GET
FACTS FROM OUR GOVERNMENT?
>> WELL, IT HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE
AS YOU KNOW THE WHOLE TIME, WE
HAVE HAD TO SUBPOENA, THREATENED
CONTEMPT, BUT WE ARE HAVING A
SHOWDOWN BETWEEN THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH AND TO THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH, AND JUST GOING TO WHAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT TO OPEN UP THE
SEGMENT, THE FACTS ARE NOT
BEARING OUT TO WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS WANTED TO BE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE FOUND COLLUSION,
WE HAVE FOUND COLLUSION BETWEEN
THE DEMOCRATS, SPECIFICALLY THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE
AND THE RUSSIANS, HOWEVER, DOES
NOT SEEM TO BE LIKE NOBODY IS
INTERESTED IN THAT COLLUSION, WE
HAVE ALSO FOUND TO FILL ANY
LEAKS, NOBODY SEEMS TO BE
INTERESTED IN GETTING TO THE
BOTTOM OF THE FELONY LEAKS, SO
IT IS ABOUT WHAT THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE LED BY
THE REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF DESPITE
WHAT WE ARE UP AGAINST A LOT OF
ODDS.
WE ARE NOT GETTING HELP FROM THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE AND ALSO
NOT GETTING ANY HELP FROM THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
>> Tucker: AND YOU ARE BEING
LIED TO.
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE OF THE LINE
GOING ON, JOHN BRENNAN, THE CIA
DIRECTOR COMES BEFORE CONGRESS
AND TESTIFIES UNDER OATH THAT HE
HAD NO IDEA WHO WROTE THE TRUMP
DOSSIER AND THAT THAT DOSSIER
FACES NO CONCLUSION BY THE INTEL
COMMUNITY.
IT SEEMS VERY MUCH LIKE A LIE,
BECAUSE THE FBI KNEW EXACTLY WHO
WROTE TO THE DOSSIER, HE LIED TO
CONGRESS UNDER OATH, WILL HE
FACE PERJURY FOR THAT?
WHY NOT IF NOT?
>> WE SENT OUT A QUESTIONNAIRE
TODAY COMMAND WE ARE ASKING
SEVERAL FORMER AND CURRENT
OFFICIALS TO ANSWER TEN SINFUL
SIMPLE QUESTIONS.
THESE ARE QUESTIONS THAT THE
PUBLIC SHOULD KNOW, AND THEY
WANT TO KNOW.
AND THAT IS WHEN DID YOU LEARN
ABOUT THE DOSSIER?
WHEN DID YOU LEARN THAT IT WAS
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATS?
WHEN DID YOU LEARN THAT THIS WAS
A POLITICAL PIECE?
THESE ARE ALL QUESTIONS THAT WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET ANSWERS TO
COME AND WE WILL.
SO PART OF WHAT WE SENT OUT
TODAY WAS THE QUESTIONNAIRE, TEN
QUESTIONS ON ANT, ALSO WAS A
COVER LETTER THAT SAYS THAT IF
YOU DO NOT ANSWER THIS YOU
WILL BE SUBPOENAED AND YOU
WILL COME BEFORE CONGRESS TO
TELL US WHEN YOU KNEW ABOUT
THIS.
>> Tucker: BUT HE DID ALREADY
SAY, HE SAID HIS PIECE, AND IT
LOOKS REALLY CLEAR THAT HE LIED,
IS -- DO YOU THINK HE LIED?
>> WE DO NOT KNOW, WE DO NOT
KNOW THE ANSWER, MAYBE HE IS
TELLING THE TRUTH, DID HE NOT
KNOW THAT THE DEMOCRATS PAID FOR
THE DOSSIER, IT IS POSSIBLE, NOW
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HE SET ON
ANOTHER SHOW WAS THAT HE KNEW
THAT PRESS PEOPLE WERE TALKING
TO HIM ABOUT THE DOSSIER IN
2016, NOW WE DO NOT KNOW WHO THE
PRESS PEOPLE WERE, IT IS
POSSIBLE THAT HE DID NOT KNOW
THE DEAD DEMOCRATS PAID FOR IT
AT THAT TIME, BUT CLEARLY HE
KNEW ABOUT THE DOSSIER BACK IN 2